okay so thank you very much to the
organizers for for this conference and
for the invitation to present here this
is joint work with Stephen Morris and so
let me motivate let me jump right in
with motivate the objects we study with
a quote from Cannes Cannes likened
professional investment to newspaper
competitions which were popular at the
time in which each competitor had to
pick not the faces that he thought were
prettiest but those which he thought
likeliest to catch the fancy of the
other competitors all of whom are
looking at the problem from the same
point of view so he goes through the
logic of this a little bit and he says
we have reached the third degree where
we devote our intelligence is to
anticipating what average opinion
expects the average opinion to be and
then you can go you can go even higher
than that so what we do in this paper is
we take is we take the objects he's
informally describing seriously and we
study them in a setting with a lot of
linearity built in but crucially
allowing heterogeneous priors in a world
where mostly people have studied before
this stuff before under common priors
and it turns out that the there's a
simple linear algebra of higher-order
expectations which we exploit to
characterize these things and to say
things about about the beauty contests
Keynes had in mind kind of times social
network so you can do both networks and
the thing that Keynes had in mind
together and so why is you know what is
this paper doing at this conference well
i think i think this higher these
higher-order expectations that Keynes is
talking about are scary and complicated
but linear algebra is simple so there
you have complexity and simplicity and
and and so as I said we were able to
generalize and unify results on beauty
contests as well as network games by a
certain kind of network centrality
characterization and we offer new ways
to use Markov chains which many people
here do much better than we do in we for
a game theoretic application so that's
that's the overview
let me jump right into the the model so
you have finitely many everything is
finite in this in this talk at least you
have finitely many agents and they have
uncertainty over two sorts of things the
first thing is an external state which
we call Thetas and think of this as like
how much oil is in the ground some some
objective external state and then there
are also types which capture what's
going on in people's heads so these are
their beliefs about the state and their
beliefs about each other so they may
have various information which makes
them let's say pessimistic or optimistic
about the amount of oil in the ground
and and further they may have
information that makes them that gives
them beliefs about each other's beliefs
and all of that is so TI is supposed to
fully determine all of that so we have a
big overall state space which we call
omega and we so we're a little
schizophrenic as to whether we're
interim or x and z much of what i say is
true under a purely interim
interpretation but to the extent that we
want to talk about some extensive stuff
and priors will say that I has a prior
pie I which is a you know a probability
distribution over the entire States
based on over the entire big state space
Omega so that's the that's the
information so I've told you this this
tells you everything about the
information structure and then there's
also an interaction structure so we'll
introduce weights gamma so the weight
gamma IJ describes how much I cares
about j in ways that our applications
will make precise but think of it for
now as an abstract wait so this will
take will take the weights to be in a
matrix big gamma and we'll assume that
it's row stochastic the Rose sum to 1
and we call this thing the interaction
structure so just as notational
convention to alert you to throughout
unless I make a typo people are in
superscripts and and indices of states
or types are in subscripts so if you're
curious if you want to know what a
letter means so I've copied some
schematic version of this notation here
on the left in case you want to refer to
it any yeah
so we will be cuz we'll be doing linear
algebra will be interested in indexing
these these finite sets but I want to
put some order on them so so you know
I've ordered I've ordered that the
state's theta 1 through through you know
the biggest one and at little m is the
index say so ditto for types so TI is a
finite finite set of types and k is the
indexes the types there is there an
order for purposes of writing down
matrices yeah assume there we picked
some arbitrary order on these guys so
just I you know for some this will be
not not so useful but I want to make
things very concrete for those who
haven't worked with this notation before
so here's an example making all of this
concrete suppose there's a 282 agent
interaction we draw a playing card and
we're going to tell let's say Jason
whether it's black or red and will tell
me whether it's a face card in a sore
something else so Jason observes one of
two signals and I observe one of three
signals and in this world my type is
fully determined by what I see so my so
Jade so is Jason so Jason's type space
is just whether he saw black or red and
mine is whether I which of my signals I
saw and theta the external state it can
be anything you want if you want them
the biggest one you just take the whole
you know exactly which card was drawn
and then we might play some bedding game
with that so that's that's how you would
you know encode some practical
interaction in this notation
that's not good uh so yeah yeah yeah so
there so that's a good point so so so
here I gave you yeah Here I made them
pretty trivial because you observe you
know but suppose I can also peek at your
card but my peak is imperfect right and
so then I would have not only not
whether I said not just which of these
three I saw but whether it looked you
know whether your card looked kind of
black or kind of red or something you're
right now and that would give me then I
would have higher order beliefs too and
non trivial ones and they're there
implicitly all stuffed in here so if you
tell me if you tell me the prior over
everything right and then you and then
you give me some information that i can
I can just Marge you know take a
conditional with respect to this thing
and that'll determine my past but pastor
your beliefs previous life yep i J and
tjk so types you should think of types
as just a an indexing can as many as
many different beliefs / anything as you
have I'll give you a type for each one
so your type fully determines everything
going on in your head so if you want
they mean the state you know you can
think of this as really a full
specification of the whole hierarchy and
I just gave it a number so and and then
input you know sort of trivially however
however i specify it i can put the prior
will contain all the probabilistic
relationships between you know different
between different beliefs you have been
does it impose any meaningful
restriction on the different beliefs
that different type of you have to say
that they all have to be Bayesian
updating
the given prior to PI I or could I have
equipment written this model and just
say each type as I believe yeah so let
me good so I think this allowed with
Jason's question to weaken you can
define the model fully in interim terms
so just each type what it literally
tells you is a distribution of beliefs
over the others types where those others
types may also have you know be all the
so the universal type space is big
enough to do this all kind of in one
step and so in principle you could be
working with with that if you wanted but
in the example many practical examples
kind of are you can write them down were
concretely within this kind of black red
framework so in to Ben's question you
can you know it we can work in a purely
interim specification for most of what
we say but it definitely imposes
non-trivial restrictions to say they're
all consistent with the common prior and
we'll see some of that in the results
yeah so finiteness will in general
everything I say we strongly believe can
be done for compact type spaces but but
in full generality I'm not so sure so so
it does it does impose some constraint
so let me I'll give you I'll come back
if you're not happy but but thank you
for okay so here's the here's the key
object that we study so fix some some
random variable Y I think of this as you
know the value of the oil in the ground
and let's define two kinds of things so
the first I'll there's two different
sorts of objects being defined on the
slide the first is a first-order belief
this is X i won so one stands for first
order and its eyes expectation about why
the letter I here appears in two places
here it's because I has private
information about about the state and
then here it's because different guys
may be using different priors so I put
an eye here if you want to take an ex
ante view then when you do when you take
conditional expectations you know eyes
taking them with respect to a different
prior than J so that's why so you can't
you know write them as conditional
expectations all with respect to one
measure in general and so so it's a
first-order expectation with respect to
eyes information
and then if once we've defined all these
first order beliefs we can define
higher-order beliefs so we can define
xoxi to hear the two well so let me talk
about the inside first so this is two
stands for second order and what is this
its eyes belief about an average of
stuff so the average is taken across a
population with weights gamma and what
is what is it that's being averaged its
various individuals first order
expectations defined in the previous
step so we have all these beliefs about
the value of oil in the ground and then
we take someone's belief about an
opinion poll of those things so the
exercise yes yeah expectation is mr.
Specter weeks distribution good so okay
so let me let's just let's make it very
concrete suppose you suppose the you
know the tea is suppose the the Y is
just a normally distributed random
variable and the tea is our signals just
with a noise around that thing right and
so this is you know so this is what
people think about the random variable
given their signals then they take this
average and then also given their
signals they can think of this
population average well you I mean when
you update based on your signal I don't
know what you're thinking in your head
this is all happening statically right
so I don't know your signal so I still
have to take if I take you know the
average of yours and jasons there's a
lot of randomness there from my
perspective that's right that's right
exactly it's a it's a TI it's measurable
with respect to this thing okay I sorry
for asking something stupid but that I
am the expert on top of the expectation
so your belief is some
beyond your type like your type T is not
fully describing and by why are you
doing that why can't rightfully just
think or present believe you could fix a
good Oh keeping that separate so we so
we want to write it if you wanted to
write it in purely interim terms you're
right that you would need only one index
right your your identity and your type
fully determines all your beliefs if you
want to take an ex ante view then then
you're taking conditional expectations
with respect to some prior measure and
if we don't have common priors then you
have to keep the eye around there
because they're not the same conditional
expectation operator and I agree but
you'll I claim its use it's valuable for
some questions too okay so good so will
be so of course what we've done for one
and two we could do here for n plus 1
and n in general a question that's all
right so UK is this this XJ is a random
variable defined like this so but that
means that X I like what I calculates
his second orders of leave he should
know that it's the other people's pride
is actually no it takes expectation over
them with regard to his beliefs priori
didn't believe so these random he
understands these random variables you
could think of so imagine these guys all
sit around before they get any
information they know the model they
know that if if you see this you'll
think this if you see this you'll think
this now they don't know what you what
you saw but they do have beliefs about
it and they take expectations with
respect to those that's right Thank You
Ilya ok so what will be particularly
concerned about is the limits of these
guys so I define these things
inductively and we're going to study the
limit as n goes to infinity and you may
ask why are you going to study that but
so I'll explain but I want to first give
a give a very concrete example which may
now be superfluous but I'll quickly go
through it so if we have this
interaction structure that's very simple
given by a cycle then typical entries in
this in these iterated average
expectations will look like well this is
a first order belief
right and then it's three pays attention
to one so then a typical second order
belief will be three threes expectation
of what one is thinking and then tues
expectation of that and so forth and you
go around so if you work with simple
gamma matrices you can think about just
sort of regular old iterated
expectations of the kinds that have been
studied in in some game theory papers
but we can think about more complicated
ones too if we let gamma be more general
so here's so so why would you care about
these big x's that I've defined so here
is one reason there are other reasons
too but I'll give one very very concrete
motivation take a simple game of its
this is this game is a popular metaphor
in a few different fields of economics
it's a game where we want to match
there's some random variable Y and we
want to match we're all concerned about
matching that thing but also
coordinating with each other so this is
some kind of organizational problem
maybe so beta is a number between zero
and one and you allocate some weight to
two matching you're unhappy you receive
a squared error loss penalty when you
mismatch why and that gets a certain
weight and then the rest of your payoff
has weight beta and comes from wanting
to match the other guys so and gamma IJ
describes how much you care about
matching with with Jay and then you get
penalized proportional to the square of
the distance from him so the point of
the slide is to cook is to deduce that
in this game equilibrium actions
actually much weaker notions than much
weaker solution concepts in equilibrium
imply this but we we can show that what
will be played in equilibrium is this
average so this is an average of these
excise for very over various ends so the
punchline is that in this in this simple
coordination game the higher-order
expectations cap basically is exactly
what's important for how you'll play and
actually in the limit we mostly will be
focusing on for this
which is that this term becomes
important that the coordination motive
dominates even though you know beta is
not quite one but it's close to one it
turns out that this is essentially equal
to the limit of these excise as n goes
to infinity so it's really high order
iterated expectations that matter for
playoff this coordination game so so
that's why that this is one motivation
for why we study this and the rest of
the slide gives the calculation for you
know how you establish this I won't go
through it but it's it's quite quite
easy all you do is you write out the
best response here which is basically
beta bar is just my shorthand for 1
minus beta so you put beta bar weight on
your best guess of why and then and then
take and then add to that a linear
combination of your best guesses of what
these other guys are doing right and
then you just plug in that best you plug
in this best response into here and if
you keep turning this crank you're going
to you're going to establish this
expression so nothing exciting there and
i won't i won't show those lines
so what can one do we show so our first
result is that these excise converge in
as n gets big to a limit that is
independent of who you are so
everybody's excise converge to the same
thing and moreover it's it's a it's
non-random all these excise converge to
a constant number convergent probability
let's say pick your favorite notion so
that sort of put puts us in business
there's some object to study and then
the rest of what we do is is analyzing
the you know what this what this
consensus actually looks like what you
know what can we say about it in terms
of the information structure and the
interaction structure so first it by
looking at the simple complete
information benchmark by by looking at
the version of this game where
everything is known and there's only the
interaction structure that's possibly
interesting we can generalize and refine
certain characterizations that people
have written in the network games
literature of these of what the limit
looks like so that's that's a structural
result one but it's and then it turns
out so we so we can we can fully Ness
the complete information case but then
it turns out the incomplete information
case relates relates to it in a nice way
and then second we can generalize a
separate literature on higher rated
expectations under common priors so
there's a well-known paper of samet that
studies that and it turns out that we
can that that's a special case in some
sense of our analysis and we can marry
that with networks so that's that sort
of the structural picture and then in
terms of new new kinds of calculations
we can do rather than unifying old
results we can we can we show you you
know once we know what this consensus
looks like we can analyze who matters
for determining it so when you have non
common priors whose priors matter and
this is the stage at which it's useful
to actually think of the prior
concretely as an ex ante thing that's
really you know that's that's real so
that's the plan
the structure of the model is common
knowledge Hans result which part so
sammich result is closely related
talents result it's it's a different I
mean it's I wouldn't say it's exact you
know alman yeah I guess once you're
willing the key thing to see is that it
highly iterated expectations actually
have to be common knowledge and once you
know their common knowledge the
agreement part is follows directly there
was another yeah so trying to wrap my
head around it but for this first result
this is the expectation result is there
any structure you need on the
interaction matrix I mean it seems like
you could basically be defining two
separate games so there is a
connectedness assumption and which I'll
get so let's jump into the results and
will will any other any other questions
before I show you more I guess what i
mean by structural results i mean things
that hold about the things that hold
about the form of this of this no matter
what the beliefs are you know i'm not
taking here i'm going to be taking
limits of very particular kinds of games
those are computations but structural
results are just relationships between
the structure is common knowledge yeah
you said structure is common knowledge
in that sense you meant the gammas you
meant yea i meant everything that's
written here that you can players can
look at a piece of paper with all this
information the gammas the that's the
the full descriptions of the type spaces
the priors so they so this is all common
knowledge okay so let me do the
convergence result formally okay
suppose that uh there's a so there's a
condition to worry about your question
which I won't say now fully but it's
called beliefs and interactions are
jointly connected so under a
connectedness condition we can say for
any random variable you have in mind
three things okay first this limit so
this is this I've already said this
informally but the limit of the X I n as
n goes to infinity exists for every
agent and this limit doesn't depend
there's a reason why I don't have a CI
here it doesn't depend on I and on who
is at the outermost expectation or does
it depend on the state it doesn't depend
on any of the randomness in the model so
this is the kid right the players all
know what what the model is but they
don't get to see each other signals of
course for each other's types as
realized and it turns out that they can
compute this knowing just that structure
without knowing the realization of the
uncertainty and not only can I tell you
this thing exists but i can tell you
pretty concretely what it looks like ok
it consensus expectation and i've copied
the formula here is a weighted average
of these guys what are these guys these
are contingent contingent beliefs so you
might think so here's what you might be
here's a natural thing to be confused
about I say that it's non random but
here there's all these all these
conditioning on realized types so what's
going on well know the key thing is I'm
not conditioning on any realizations
before we before we get any information
we can sit and I can think you know what
if Jason were optimistic Jason today
what would he think what if Jason were
pessimistic Jason I could write all
those things so I know all these numbers
and it turns out that the consensus
expectation is a weighted average of all
these numbers okay and I'll tell you
much more about these weights ppi k
which are sort of played the starring
role yep i'm not getting intuition for
this let me die to the safe is a good
example in
wrong okay there isn't time and there
are two players and they get a signal
which is fully informative yeah so this
connect in this assumption will rule
that kind of thing out it'll rule out
perfect common knowledge it'll rule out
that we that we play completely
disconnected games in terms of
interaction and it'll rule out some
other things too but but so your example
is exactly the edge case that we need to
rule out sorry for interrupting what
just the fact that people are getting
informative signal isn't that already
prevent you from having a an answer
which does not depend on the state well
what's most interesting is that as soon
as you move away from your edge cases
even the tiniest way so assume that I
have the slightest uncertainty about
what you saw right so your example is
suppose that it's a lot of oil or a
little oil and it's common knowledge
which it is and then you can't have
anything interesting happening but as
long as I have the slightest uncertainty
about about how much there is about how
much you think there is okay then then
we're immediately this result now
applies so that's surprising I at least
I it's not our result actually it was
first observed by shin and Williamson
but um but yeah so so that that was a
helpful edge case to point out so I
liked you a little bit on the slide what
I the limit that I wrote there doesn't
actually always exist so everything on
the slide remains the same except i'm
going to change this to something that
actually now the theorem is really a
theorem what this thing is is a kya
Cesaro Sam basically so rather than
looking at the limit of the Xin I look
at the average of them for out in the
tail and when the limit exists they're
the same and and this is defined even
when the limits not defined so now now
I've been honest with you so this is
really but remember this is what matters
for the game actually so so all our
theorems about are about this but when
the limit exists they coincide okay so
let me give you a sense of the argument
about what's going on here and then
you'll be able and then and then that's
really the main sort of technical point
I want to leave you with and will and
then I'll discuss you know everything
will follow in a pretty easy way once we
understand this so the first to study
these objects let's go to the linear
algebra world how are we going to do
that well why don't we keep
think of this is a random variable but
it's measurable with respect to eyes
information so since I has finitely many
types let's just write out all the all
the things it is for each type right so
so you can list you can think of this
guy is just a vector with one entry per
type of I recording that guy's
conditional expectation and moreover we
can stack these once we have these
vectors defined individual by individual
we can stack them up in a big big vector
one for me one for Mohammed and you know
one part of the vector for me one for
Mohammed that makes a big vector that's
this big so the key observation is that
the formula defining these iterated
average expectations is a linear formula
in fact Markovian in in the previous
step and once we know that we can write
the iteration the key the key inductive
definition of what we study right here
we can write that guy in matrix notation
and everybody knows how powers of Markov
matrices behave so so things are pretty
straightforward and and you know looking
ahead a little bit if we represent the
matrix as a network we can relate high
order beliefs to network properties and
that's really the the payoff from doing
it this way so what is so let me make
this a little more concrete since this
is this is a very wordy overview but
what's where are the symbols well so
this vector the KF entry of this vector
captures what the KS type of I thinks
about the random you know thinks at
stage n plus 1 and I'll write it I'll
just recall this is just recalling the
definition ok and now i can write out
the i can take this conditional
expectation and just write it out you
know foolishly take the problem you know
undergraduate probability book and write
down the the form of this conditional
expectation but the key so you don't
need to look at this that much all you
need to observe about it is that it's is
that it's a linear formula and you can
actually check that all these
coefficients sum up to 1 row by row so
the summer so you know this is not fun
to look at but this is ok I can I can
just write X the next stage long vector
X as some matrix times the pre
a stage long vector and I can describe
that matrix to you if we think you know
recall the correspondence between
matrices and weighted directed graphs
where the arrows capture the matrix
entries you know the this matrix is I've
kind of drawn it here there are as so
how many rows are there well there's one
for every type of every agent so here
are all of eyes types here all of J's
types and the arrow from type from a
given type of me to a given type of
Jason is has weight that's composed of
two things how much I care about jason
is a person that's gamma IJ and then the
subjective belief that this type of me
puts on that type of Jason so that's
that's the matrix B I fully described it
and by let you can check that this is a
Markov matrix so now we care about we
care about its asymptotic properties
well that's easy right we know now that
it's that its limit and so I'm being a
little loose here because I am acting
like it exists and there's the usual
periodicity worry but you know don't
worry if if x infinity so so when when
this is well defined I can just say x
infinity is the limit of this matrix as
n goes to infinity times the initial
vector times x1 and from what we know
about about Markov chains we can we know
that what this is equal to is a constant
vector every entry of which is the dot
product of the stationary distribution
of P of B the matrix with the initial
vector x1 so we can but the takeaway
from the slide is once we make this
transformation this is all just
elementary Markov chains so we can
characterize we can characterize what
this limit is and the key observation is
that we now that we know exactly what B
is we know what this matrix is we know
everything that this P can depend on
okay it since it's the stationary
distribution of this matrix it can only
depend on stuff in that matrix and in
particular you know it's fully
determined by these interaction weights
and beliefs about each other's types so
you can think of this as a decoupling
result if I go back to the statement of
the theorem this actually decouples what
see depends on into peas which depend on
what I just said and then this stuff
which depends on the actual why we care
about the
variables so it decouples the kind of
intrinsic insurgency beliefs about each
other's types and the external random
variable Y so that's the real value
there because this decomposition could
be true in kind of a stupid way you can
always write this if you're if you're if
you don't put any constraints on your
pie but but now that we know some stuff
about what determines p I this this has
content so so now let me tell you so
that's the now in the last ten minutes I
can we can actually milk this and get
some get some insight out of it so let
me tell you what I call the structural
results but before that formal statement
of the connectedness condition now that
I've told you about matrix B the
connected this condition is just that
that guy is a strongly connected is an
irreducible matrix or has a strongly
connected graph which is so so this
condition i should say is stronger than
the then either the network or a belief
connectedness separately so you you need
you need both um okay so let me now let
me let's let's let's get some let's get
some mileage out of this so let's do a
silly special case but that turns out to
be illuminating let's suppose there's
complete information so everybody's type
isn't is a singleton so there's nothing
interesting going on it may still be
that agents have different beliefs about
so just all the time I have a different
belief about oil in the ground than you
do we have different priors that's
allowed okay but but everything else and
that's known to everything is known so
let me remind you of a definition the
eigenvector centrality with respect to
the interaction structure gamma is
defined as you know a vector e
satisfying this equation this just says
that e is a left eigenvector of gamma
with eigenvalue 1 suitably normalized
your centrality is this is page rank
your centrality is a weighted sum of
other people's centrality is weighted by
how much they care about you so if
there's no incomplete information type
spaces or Singleton's and you can easily
see that this B matrix i defined is just
the interaction matrix right there's no
all the pies all the pie stuff is
trivial so in this case p the this
vector of weights which determines the
outcome is just the eigenvector
centrality vector of the according to
the interaction structure or another
words the consensus expectation is a
weighted average of individuals priors
weighted by how central they are in the
interaction network so this case is well
known this has been studied in the
network games literature so so this is
this is a special case now it turns out
that something that this is that that
something much more interesting is true
which will which is a big generalization
of this it's always the case no matter
what the information and interaction
structure is that the sum of weights on
a person's types is equal to his
eigenvector centrality in the network so
jason has a bunch of types there's happy
Jason sad Jason Jason who thinks that
I'm happy and if you sum the weights of
all his types these pik s then you get
Jason centrality in the interaction
network which you could have computed
without knowing anything about the
information structure so that that's
sort of the sense in which we refine the
standard centrality analysis in the
complete information case it's your
centrality and gamma that matters in
general your centrality and gamma is
shared out among your various types okay
so that means that we can write we can
write this decomposition where the the
weight that type K of person I gets is a
product of two things it's the product
of his weight as a person eii times some
number Rik and by what I've just said
what we know these numbers sum to 1 ok
so this these ours generalize the notion
of a prior on player on player eyes
types that's a precise statement in the
following sense if there is a common
prior over types that is if our interim
beliefs are consistent with some joint
distribution on the on the whole type
space the product of all our types if
there's some joint distribution that
gives rise to all our interim beliefs
then it turns out that these ours just
are the the prior beliefs on our types
according to that comment prior ok but
this decomposition is valid even when
that's not true it's valid completely
generally and so this this R is a kind
of substitute it's a stand-in for a
common prior even when there's no common
prior and if you want to ask me during
Q&A I can give you a more precise
version of this standing claim any
questions getting lonely up here
yeah so if you consume in this condition
within this invasion I can represent
right up this is notion in page rank
that as you are an individual trying to
compute these measures like if you're
trying to set an expectation after some
point you might get bored in Europe and
thank you so the solution of class nice
big expectation you are the starting
point you could give up sometimes yeah
that sound may get computationally
easier yeah well whereas the so the
getting indicating board is distributed
you get bored at some random stage of
this you want to get bored after four
cents to get more at every point with
point one for the vanity but so that
Markov chain naturally mix is very fast
track because you yeah yeah so let me
talk to you more about that in basically
the we're we're we're getting away so
your your thing has to do with I think
the low powers of be right the because
you take only a few steps right and if
you look if we look back at like the
game in the game it was an average so as
beta goes up to one as you can't really
care about coordinating you know I care
about coordinating with Jason but he
cares about coordinating with you and
that really takes me far from me but for
low coordination motives it's only the
first few steps that matters so that's
the correspondence when we really care
about coordinating that gives that gives
rise to this distant contagion of stuff
but for low beta it's the first few
powers that matter unfortunately the
interesting things I have to say our
about the high powers okay so so a
consequence of this statement that I
just made is that if there are common
part yeah more questions spin
individual specific priors from the
weights are the weights that's a good
question no they're in general unrelated
they're there or if they are related to
the weights and it's in a complicated
way that we don't know so there's no
natural formula unless okay so a
consequence of what I just said is if
there are common priors over types we
can get exactly the same formula that we
got in the in the trivial case of
complete information so this this this I
don't know should surprise you I think
because the complete information case is
super silly but common priors over types
is like is like what economist study all
the time and and so type spaces can be
super big but it turns out that that
they completely wash out in a sense
right there's there's nothing about the
structure of pi of private information
here so and there's an easy proof of
this if we write the general formula for
consensus expectation and then we use
our decomposition that we just
established where it's player wait times
these ours and then you use the fact
that I just told you that in the common
prior case over the this is just equal
to the prior probability of type k then
you immediately see that this guy inside
by the law of iterated expectations is
just to the prior expectation according
to I of the random variable so you can
and moreover okay so that's so there's
one more thing you can get out of this
if if these these guys are actually all
the same if if these guys are all the
same because we have common priors over
the external stuff as well then this is
just the common prior so that's
essentially that's a manifestation of
sandwich result in our setting that when
there is a common prior about why then
despite all this interesting interaction
and updating and whatever everything
washes out and what we play in the
coordination game is just a common prior
expectation of Y strange but true so we
so but it turns out that what's really
important is common prior over types
right if you don't have common prior
over types this result is adjusted in a
relatively trivial way you just wait by
individual centrality but it's about as
simple again the inter
you have almost come on prior say one of
you guys has a different tire but n
minus one of them ever come on fire or
something of this form can you say
anything up how much DC musume I will
tell you the best thing I know about
that as my last result okay so so let me
so I time I who is my god okay five
minutes so so I'm not going to go
through all the content of this slide
but basically under what we've learned
is under common priors private
information washes out in a very very
strong sense all the structures that I
set up ends up kind of not mattering
right because the consensus expectation
is not non-random so stuff doesn't
depend on realizations and it doesn't
even depend on the information structure
it doesn't depend on any of these
details of what people believe about
each other so in general this second
bullet doesn't hold you can the the
consensus begins to depend in an
interesting way on the structure of
private information so so the rest of
the talk is is about is telling you
about that and I think I'm going to we
have an example quickly so the this
example which I won't go through but it
answers Ben and malicious question that
in general once you will once you relax
common prior is over types you can get
very goofy interactions between the
network structure and the information
structure and you can't you know it so
basically dip it you can take one
network that's a cycle clockwise and
other networks that's a cycle
counterclockwise the predictions are
completely different even though the
model is sort of symmetric in terms of
all the priors and everything so like
the individuals priors are symmetric
between these cases so I'll talk to you
more about that counter example or ask
me in Q&A but there is a counter example
showing that stuff can get weird quickly
but i wanna the are sort of cut the
results where we can do interesting
calculations are about whose priors
matter and the so that's the last thing
i want to tell you about when you have
guys with different priors you really
want to take an ex ante view of the
situation can we say that it'll be my
priors that matter for determining the
the play of the game so let me let me
tell you what we know remember that in
common priors over types it was the more
central guys whose priors mattered that
was the result i just rode so let's take
a quite different setting now no common
priors but let's suppose that
we have agents who receive signals so
there's some true state of interest and
agents receive signals about it which
are correct with probability 1 minus
epsilon and otherwise they have some
weird you know when you're being lied to
you may be lied to in some kind of
interesting way you know so a simple
case is you get the truth with
probability 1 minus epsilon and random
noise uniform otherwise but you can
imagine other structures we study a
structure that game theorists have have
focused on called common interpretation
of signals which has the following
structure we agree about how signals are
distributed given the state so we all
know this and we all have the same
distributions of error in mind
conditional on the state theta but we
may have different priors about theta so
I may think I may be much more
optimistic about oil ex ante than you
are but we agree about how our
instruments work and stuff so here's
what we can here's what we can show
suppose that all these error
probabilities are going to 0 so we're
converging to the complete information
game where instruments are perfectly
precise but one of them let's say guy j
is epsilon converges to 0 much slower
than the others so he remains his error
rate remains high while the others are
relatively low but all of them are going
to 0 then I claim that it's only guy j's
priors that will matter okay so it's the
guy who's so this is a fact about
Cortese beauty contests coordination
games ignorant people win right because
I say I don't know anything I always do
I always just take my prior action don't
respond to my information in any way
then you know what I'll do right so
insofar as you care about coordinating
with me mostly you'll just take my you
know the ignorant ones prior action and
everybody will coordinate on that it
turns out that this is true even when
you take these limits we're we're we're
not we're not ignorant anymore
everybody's quite well-informed but it's
still the relatively ignorant guy whose
priors determine the play and so that's
that's the kind of result we can show
and what kind of math is involved in
this well remember that to characterize
the outcome for any particular
environment we had to study the
stationary distribution of this Markov
chain be now as we're taking these
absalon's 20 we're studying a sequence
of games where the bees are indexed by
epsilon and actually in the limit since
we're taking the complete information
limit the as the B becomes what you guys
were worried about the completely
disconnected case where we know exactly
what's going on so this B splits up into
a bunch of boring components so to
understand to characterize how the what
the consensus is we have to analyze the
limits of Markov chains that are tending
to a disconnected limit right so
continuity of Markov chains is nice when
you're in your connected Markov chains
but when you go to disconnected once
things get goofy and end you and so it
turns out that in even to state this
result correctly even to say at what
rate you know what it means for epsilon
I to go much slower you have to really
worry about the structure of the of the
interim beliefs as captured by this
matrix B and four different graph
structure of it there will be you know
different rates required so to be very
concrete the structure of the errors is
going to determine what rate assumption
i need to make whether i need epsilon J
to be big relative to the square of the
other guys epsilon zor to the cube or
whatever and I can read that off from
the graph structure and the proofs of
this kind of thing go go via the Markov
chain tree lemma which we all love okay
so so this is this is what I wanted to
say I'll leave this conclusion slide up
I want to say that many many people this
is you know I put the classic references
like salmon and these network games
before but this is a exciting time for
us / you know stressful time because
they're all these hard people publishing
papers right now about very about
related things so i put i put the ones
we knew about please tell me about
others and i want to leave you with
these punchlines that this consensus
expectations are sort of even though
they're defined really simply there's
kind of a lot going on you could weave
and and they generalize things that
people have cared about another's
literature other literature's and for me
the most important thing is that if you
have markov chain intuition from kind of
physical you know the physics way of
thinking about Markov chains you can now
start using it to say stuff about higher
order beliefs which are otherwise scary
so so that's that's what i want to say
i'm happy to
take some questions Julia so I remember
correctly against a squat was a
application with financial markets and
so your game is maybe somewhat but not
exactly what you think is in a financial
markets of course the result is pretty
pessimistic that there is no information
litigation at all so is there some way
to related to financial market and is
there any information revelation in
their game before realistic that's a
great question we wrote down just to
make to make the connection explicit we
wrote down a very stylized trading game
which is kind of a hot potato asset you
with very small probability eat it but
mostly you sell it off so in that case
there's no aggregation but but more for
more realistic dynamic I think the model
is different enough that it's not going
to directly say anything about more
realistic information aggregation and
finance but we Keynes actually thought
that the that the phenomenon he
highlighted was going to lead to like
volatility and things being very very
sensitive to sun spots and whatever and
so you can think of that the best thing
we have to say in connection to that is
if you because things depend things are
deterministic in a component but they
depend very sensitively on the structure
of the connectedness structure of the
matrix B so if you think of that
changing somehow if something that was
not viewed as plausible suddenly becomes
plausible then you can have big jumps so
that's our Jason
yeah appreciate it at the time I was
wondering if you could maybe 50 words
not obviously know this right so the
matrix B is it can be defined purely in
terms of interim beliefs all it just
cares about conditional beliefs on each
other's types but for but the ex-ante
things the places where i use ex ante is
so i can say whose priors matter in the
interim world there's not even such a
thing as Jason's prior so if you're
willing to commit and think there is
some stage before the game where we have
priors over what our signals will be
then we can talk about whose priors
matters so that's the distinction I just
wanted a little bit malicious question
so suppose I observe behavior in this
game and I see everyone's actions and
I'm I'm thinking in this beta close to
one case so that people are really
playing the consensus expectations you
said before that you can't back out
exactly what the prior what the interim
beliefs are but are there any
non-trivial restrictions on the intern
beliefs in other words what can we learn
about editor believes from behavior I
see if you get to observe the consensus
what can you learn about in our beliefs
yeah um yeah so these extreme will I
mean right or you can ask for putting
some substance of restrictions on the
interim beliefs what is implied about
what are the falsifiable so we are
thinking about though as you might not
be surprised by Steven and I are
thinking about those extremal questions
they turn out to be hard but we do we
think there are some characterizations
on the con you know the convex polytope
in which the consensus measure that
gives rise to this consensus expectation
lies but we don't have much to say but I
agree with you that it's a super
interesting question i guess i should
stop right sake remaining questions
offline